[Music]
what is this you're holding our sir it's
a marine toad Conan really you should
probably be holding on to it and get
used to this
what okay should I just take a look at
the face on this guy is it okay to hold
him is he dangerous at all well no he's
not dangerous it's an interesting
creature there might get them a little
bit closer up to the shoulders there
give him a little like shoulder support
okay
all right Hold'em I am B I'm gonna frog
bra what are you talking about here we
go these are among the largest frogs in
the world this is a toad
this one weighs about three pounds I've
collected a toad in Africa or actually a
frog in Africa that weighs twice as much
twice as much as this one it's about a
yard long with its legs extended but
this is still a pretty you know hefty
nice toad where's the other chick a
little under the chin they like that
yeah the the main thing about these
toads is that they're hallucinogenic
there he mean they're hallucinogenic
people have actually been arrested for
possessing a toad with the intent to
lick so do not look like you want to
lick this toad but now you make me just
want to do it
this is a habit you don't want to lick
[Music]
every night you can actually die from
licking this toted bring that up now
didn't you see me move in for the lick
and you said nothing
well it's there's a church chef we're
licking toads it's the Church of the
toad of light yes in the 1980s a
fantastic Church I think it died out
eventually they all wondered off a cliff
yeah what are these these are the jungle
nymphs they're fabulous they're walking
sticks big hefty ones the females are
the green ones the males are the scrawny
brown ones and they really whoo they
have a look at elastic display with the
wings and what are their okay and what
are they are they date you said they're
dangerous we don't wanna mess around
what could they do they throw their legs
at you and these spines into your skin
but it's alright you're not gonna do
anything with right well they throw
their legs at you they detach the leg
and her--let this one's coming at me
right now the thing about the the
walking sticks is that the males aren't
they're kind of wimpy looking and in
fact the females of some species
completely have dropped out the males
there is one species that hasn't had sex
in a million years of all virgin births
yeah I get that
okay our vinaigrette except restaurants
those species from Arizona they're
actually a huge number of them down in
Arizona the cool thing is that they give
off the most acid concentrated acid of
any species you actually smell them
they're called vinegaroon sometimes the
whip scorpions and it's not vinegar yeah
it's you press the back leg they walk we
shoot some acid asked why are you trying
to shoot Andy why don't you shoot at it
yourself and let's get a real nice
demonstration there no not you Andy I
mean dr. bugs I see you yeah well you
know the really cool thing is that these
if there was a Nobel Prize for weird sex
this animal would have it in what way
what are they into these things have
their sex takes 13 hours it starts with
something we're using sound long to me
[Applause]
come to think of it yeah we can we can
do the calculations later but they are
said to have those complicated SEC you
can see what you think it starts with
the male chasing the female pretty
typical move male face it chase a team
and then they wrestle he's actually
wrestled for a couple hours and they
basically push each up each other up in
the air there's like all this juggling
going on and then the male has to calm
down the female he puts her feet in his
mouth and she trembles with excitement
and then he climbs up on top and presses
her down and masturbates for about three
hours
what is your problem
I thought we were classing up the show
we have an entomologist on and you're
like hitting masturbates